hey there welcome back I'm in Des Moines
Iowa where tonight we're gonna find out
the very first results of the 2020
presidential race now as the country
grows more urban and diverse some people
wonder why campaigning still begins here
in this overwhelmingly white and rural
state ed O'Keefe has been here for weeks
and we asked him to look back in time to
find out why the Heartland state here
got to kick off our presidential
elections
Eady good morning again good to see you
what do you got for us well look you
know up in New Hampshire they like to
say Iowa picks corn and they pick the
presidents but Democrats here and I
would do have a pretty good track record
at predicting their party's eventual
presidential nominee so we set out to
ask why Iowa Thank You Iowa if you build
it they will come
Iowans troop to caucus meetings across
the state and record numbers tonight for
five decades these snowy corn fields
have yielded a crop of future presidents
Iowa has changed the political landscape
overnight pigs may outnumber people here
but the Iowans we met are determined to
make sure they count
you're gonna make me the next president
get in the fight thank you for being
here
[Music]
shocker
and just how much does Iowa matter to
those candidates well back in the 70s
Roger Mudd put it this way it will be a
psychological break for some of them it
will be a probably a disaster for others
appropriately it took a farmer to put
Iowa on the political map I was hoping
to come in first but to come in two to
one ahead of the nice candidate was a
very gratifying thing he's done it with
the hard work without any real support
or alliances and without even spending
the week before the caucuses in Iowa by
the eighties the Hawkeye State had
become must stop on the way to the White
House so the Iowa caucuses got the
battle for the presidency off to a
stunning start Bush 33 percent Reagan 27
leaving the loser come up with creative
excuses if I had to lose one I'm glad it
was a straw vote not a primary four
years later former Democratic Vice
President Walter Mondale cleaned up in
Iowa hardly because over two-thirds of
Mondale's voters said they were for him
because he could beat Ronald Reagan he
didn't fewer than half of Republicans
who finished first here went on to win
the GOP nomination but more often Iowa
Democrats do get it right picking all
but three of the eventual nominees the
comeback Kerry even when the rest of us
didn't know to expect it the race for
the Democratic presidential nomination
looks a whole lot different tonight
after that Howard Dean's presidential
dreams screeched to a halt
whether Roe's reaction from Republicans
or Democrats it was about the same
bizarre eerie weird odd the votes have
been cast but four years later Iowa
Democrats did place their hopes in
change the moines resident Tracy Murphy
hopes it can happen again but even if
she dispatched Bernie Sanders volunteers
from her home where if he wondered
whether this wait should fall on her
state
I love the popularity of being first in
the nation I love all the attention that
we get
but at the same time I don't think that
it should be a play favorites to Iowa
all the time and sometimes maybe
somebody else you get to be first the
poles heading into tonight's caucuses
show Bernie Sanders in the lead but we
won't know until people actually stand
up in front of their neighbors at those
caucuses whether Iowa may have yet
another shotgun store tonight they're
standing up in front of your neighbors
think it's important to point out
because it's not a secret ballot in Iowa
so what is it what does Iowa say in its
defense about holding the caucus one of
the most frequent defenses we got from
voters from people who run the caucuses
you may think we're not diverse but
remember in 2016 we picked a woman in
2008 we picked a black man in 2016 this
state gave Hispanic American Ted Cruz
the first victory in a Republican caucus
inside so don't think that we can't see
through that yeah and can pick diversity
and so these caucuses are run by the
parties not the stage so the party's
really get to decide this year it feels
like if they don't pick a winner someone
who can be President Trump on the
Democrat side that could lead to change
absolutely and they're aware of that and
that weighs on the minds of a lot of
voters who don't support Bernie Sanders
all right thank you very much
you